hey you guys we're doing another
flickers of fear
my movie review show so here's a movie
this was uh recommended to me by at
least two or three uh listeners
after watching it i can totally see why
it was recommended to me
because this movie which is called the
clove hitch killer and came out in 2018
is very very obviously based on
btk aka dennis raider who obviously we
talk about a lot on our show
this is it's like it's a fictional movie
but the killer in it is actually
pretty clearly based on dennis raider
even though weirdly like a lot of the
reviews of it don't really mention that
i think
on decider it mentioned it you know the
guy that wrote
the screenplay whose name was
christopher ford and the director of it
duncan uh skyles i think his name is
they very specifically said they were
fascinated by
the btk killer and wanted to kind of
make a movie
exploring maybe the family dynamic of
what was going on
with uh with that which is something
that i'm kind of interested in because
i've always kind of wondered that as
well
particularly you know with these serial
killers that have
seemingly normal family lives as dennis
raider seemed to and also serial killers
that stopped for a really long time so
that's another thing that this movie
explores
now this movie is on it's pretty much on
uh
you know any major streaming service you
want to name i watched it on hulu but
then i discovered it's also on
netflix at least in the u.s and uh
pretty sure it's on amazon prime as well
so there's lots and lots of places you
can watch it and i actually really would
recommend it
it seems like most of the reviews of it
seem like
they're really positive like i saw a lot
of really positive reviews of it but
then
there was some people that really really
didn't like it they thought it was too
boring or too slow
or just or too unbelievable or various
other things like
for whatever reason they didn't really
like it but
i don't know i thought this was like a
really really good film and it's not
maybe what you're expecting when you
think oh it's a serial killer movie
it's not about you know like a cop
chasing a serial killer but you know
we've seen
that before it's not really about the
serial killer
you know trying to get inside his head
or anything like that we've had a lot of
movies like that too this one's doing
something a little bit different
which i thought was really intriguing
now is it
a horror movie sort of um it's like
psychological horror i would probably
call it more like a thriller or a
mystery
or you know maybe a horror tinge drama
that doesn't sound too weird but it's
like there's not
a lot of violence in it um you don't
even really
see the serial killer in the movie the
clove hitch killer you don't even really
see him
you know attacking a victim until almost
the end well actually i guess it's sort
of like toward the
end of the middle or i don't know if
that makes any sense this also does
something really interesting
it kind of goes in a direction you don't
expect leave some ambiguity for a while
so you're almost kind of thinking oh
maybe it's not going to go and it goes
in a lot of directions that
i wasn't expecting it to go in which i
really really liked so
what the story behind this is there's
this
tiny tiny little town in kentucky called
clarksville and it's just really really
small super super religious super
conservative town
i kind of feel like i don't know if this
movie is set nowadays
because it was hard to tell because well
because this was
such a tiny like backwards little town
so it could have been you know it could
have been the 90s it could have been now
i don't really know
but because the uh the main teenager
character
his cell phone was like a flip phone
which made me think it was maybe the 90s
or the early
2000s but then his friend
she had like a slightly more modern cell
phone so maybe it was
sort of now it doesn't really matter but
i'm just saying that
it was kind of hard to tell because the
town was so
small and so insular and um you know so
i couldn't really tell like when it was
supposed to be going on and maybe they
just gave
the kid this really really old cell
phone
so he wouldn't be tempted to like look
at porn or whatever so this family is
the burn burnsides
and they're a very uh you know very very
religious very conservative family
um basically you can't swear you can't
even drink soda you know everything is
just very and their whole lives pretty
much revolve around
the church um and the boy scouts or
whatever this movie's equivalent to the
boy scouts is i think it's called the
order of light which i guess is maybe
more
i don't know if they're supposed to be
actual boy scouts or if it's just kind
of like an even more christian boy
scouts i'm not really sure
but so the main character is named tyler
and he's a 16 year old boy
it should be noted that in this town of
clarksville kentucky
there was 10 years ago
there was a series of murders that were
undertaken by
a dude only known as the clove hitch
killer
um i believe it was 13 women that were
killed and if you know anything about
the btk case uh they were killed very
much like uh btk's victims were
they were not raped but they were you
know the
the perpetrator would break into their
house and would
tie them up hog tie them and uh you know
usually strangle them or suffocate them
by putting a bag over their head or
something like that
so a lot of a lot of women were killed
and they never solved it
and 10 years went by and there haven't
been any new ones so
tyler uh he's in the boy scouts his dad
don burnside played by uh dylan
mcdermott who is actually really
brilliant in this
he's playing this kind of like ned
flanders-y
he's not that over the top but he's just
kind of like the dorky
you know super christian dad and he you
know he tells stupid dad jokes and he's
just very like
you know he he's very much like that but
because you know that
probably he's a serial killer it kind of
lends that performance like a real
sinister edge which i think was like
really well done so dylan mcdermott is
like [ __ ] great in this
so tyler you know everybody kind of
knows about the murders because they
still have a vigil you know every year
for the victims or whatever but there
really hasn't been any movement on the
case in 10 years and the killer has not
struck again in all that time
so tyler as it happens has this kind of
crush on a girl
in his class and he's gonna sneak out
and pick her up now when he sneaks out
to pick her up he basically steals his
dad's truck like his dad don is a i
think he's a handyman
and uh so he's got like the magnets on
the side of his work truck or whatever
so tyler like takes the magnets off and
goes and picks up the girl and then they
go to the car and they're gonna make out
or whatever
and in the process of the pre-makeout
uh session the girl i can't remember
what her character's name was she's not
in it very much but
she finds this kind of torn magazine
picture like underneath the passenger
seat i think it is
of a woman in bondage like she's all
tied up she has a ball gag or whatever
now because tyler has perhaps unwisely
told this girl that this is his truck
and not his dad's truck uh the girl
thinks that the picture belongs to him
and since she's also like a super
super conservative christian whereas
like you know no porn allowed no
gay people allowed no nothing nothing
she is very very offended by this
and he's like hey it's not mine she
doesn't believe him
and like an [ __ ] basically the next
day
she tells everybody well she says she
tells one person
that oh i went out this tyler dude and i
found this like creepy [ __ ] in his
car like i found this porn in his car
and he's a perv
and then it gets around the whole school
that he's a perv you know so now his
friends won't hang out with him anymore
so he is essentially ostracized
because of this one picture which isn't
even his so these are the kinds of
people that you're dealing with
in this movie which i know are but there
are real people like this but you know
what i mean so
but it's interesting like because like i
said btk
you know also was a leader in the church
and also was you know a boy scout like a
you know boy scout leader or whatever so
you know pretty obviously you know don
burnside in this is
based off of him very very strongly you
know and he also had a wife and kids and
a normal life and nobody suspected
anything and he also took a break for a
really long time
so that's kind of what's going on here
so
because tyler uh you know found this
thing
like that they found his thing in this
in his dad's truck he gets like really
really
not suspicious immediately he's just
kind of like
i wonder why i didn't know dad was into
that kind of stuff because you know this
this family is just like ridiculously
wholesome but all but in a real like
kind of creepy
way you know what i mean so
he starts thinking i wonder if he's got
more stuff i don't know if he's just
like looking for more porn
or if it's already in the back of his
mind that maybe there's something more
sinister going on
but he knows that his dad he has this
shed in the backyard that he's always
kind of hanging out in and it's always
locked like with a padlock
now the mom is kind of like oblivious
she's just like in there cutting coupons
so your dad has his hobbies or whatever
and it's like yeah he certainly does
that's for sure
so tyler uh figures out the combination
of the uh you know the the lock that's
on the shed
and he goes in there and underneath the
floorboard
he finds this box that has some bondage
magazines in it
which you know whatever and it's like
he's shocked but
he's a 16 year old super christian kid
from kentucky so he's shocked about that
but the thing that makes him maybe think
that there's something worse going on
is at the very bottom of this box he
finds a polaroid picture
of a tied up middle-aged woman who looks
pretty scared
and someone has written on this polaroid
picture lucky's favorite
nora now at this point he starts to
suspect
hey maybe my dad is the clove hitch
killer
who they never caught so he does a
little bit of a web search sneaking
because he's also not allowed to go on
the internet because you know
porn so he goes down in the middle of
the night and like sneaks around
and he finds out that indeed one of the
clove hitch killer's victims was named
nora devlin and the pictures of the
woman look very much
like the picture that he found in his
dad's shed
now at this point like i said i don't
i don't know if i really want to spoil
this because i do want people to watch
it but if i don't spoil it
then i can't really talk that much more
about it so maybe i will
so if you don't if you don't want to
know what happens in this or like what
happens toward the middle and the end
then maybe click off and go watch the
movie like i said it's everywhere it's
on hulu it's on netflix it's on amazon
prime it's all over the place
so you can watch it and then come back
and uh
you know we'll kind of discuss what's
going on in the [ __ ] but
like i said it's really hard to talk
about any farther than that without
saying like you know what twists and
turns that it takes because i think
that's one of the
things that i liked the best about it
was that it did
some unexpected things with the serial
killer mythology or what you would do
if you suspected that your dad was a
serial killer because this is something
i've always kind of wondered about
and i think we talked about it on our
btk show and we've talked about on other
serial killer shows
serial killers that have you know
supposedly normal
family lives and jobs and stuff like
that and no one suspects them and they
do it for decades and decades
that's really fascinating to me because
i cannot imagine
what it would be like to find out that
you'd been
you know married to this dude for 30
years or you know you this dude had been
your dad for 16 years
and you never suspected anything and
then you found out that he was a serial
killer i just can't imagine
what that would do to your life you know
what i mean so i think that was a really
cool thing to like explore in this movie
so at this point i should note that
tyler
uh because he was ostracized by all his
horribly uptight judgmental
uh [ __ ] friends because they
now they all think he's a perv because
they thought that s m picture was his
um he is kind of hanging out with the
weird girl who is really not all that
weird she's just super into true crime
and she's not religious
so that basically makes her like which
you know what i mean
in this town pretty much so he starts
hanging out with her and it turns out
that she
is actually uh fascinated by the clove
hitch killer and
because she lives with this older woman
that was i think she was like a
journalist or an investigator on the
case or something like that so she has a
lot of files on it
now you find out later on and like i
said this is spoiler spoilers so if you
don't want anything to know you know
if you don't want to know anything about
the movie i'm going to kind of spoil it
from this point on so this is kind of
your final warning but you find out
later on
uh and you kind of suspect this pretty
early in the movie but you find out
later on that um
this girl's uh mom was actually one of
the clove hitch
victims because i think there ended up
being more than the police like knew
about you know what i mean
so there so there's that whole thing so
that's why she's kind of obsessed with
it so
when they work together now initially
when tyler finds all this [ __ ] on his
own
he's like hey i found this polaroid
picture he tells to this uh to the girl
whose name is cassie by the way at first
she kind of like blows him off
and then like she goes over to dinner at
their house
because there's this whole thing where
he kind of gets busted
and like his dad is like oh he's got a
girlfriend and it's like we have to meet
her so even though they're not
boyfriend and girlfriend which i really
like that they
didn't go that route they didn't go like
oh it's a teen romance type of thing
these two end up like working together
like
to solve this mystery to find out if his
dad is really the clove hitch killer
but they don't there's not like any
romance between them really it's like
they like each other they're friends but
i kind of like that they didn't like
shoehorn that in there they're just kind
of hanging out because they have a
mutual
interest uh you know and then and they
do like at the end they do like really
like look out for each other and [ __ ]
like that so obviously they care about
each other but it's like a friend thing
which i thought was kind of cool
so uh so cassie comes over to dinner and
you know she makes kind of some jokes
and
about being a wiccan and stuff like that
just to see what they'll do which i
which was a really really funny scene
there's actually some really funny like
dark comedy in this like not it's not
real overt
but a lot of the stuff that's kind of
like situational like i just found it
really amusing like especially this
especially cassie's character because
she's kind of like a smart ass but not
obnoxiously
so she just very straight faces like
yeah i'm pretty much an atheist
i'm kind of like looking into wicca
maybe and like all this other kind of
stuff and they're all kind of horrified
but trying like not to be horrified
so i think it's like really funny but so
after she comes over to the thing and
he's told her about the polaroid
but then he's they're taking her home
and she's just kind of like no
dude your dad's not clove hitch come on
what ends up happening then
is that because he had told her about
the polaroid and because it said lucky's
favorite on it
um she kind of goes back through her
files because it's still kind of going
around in the back of her head and she
comes out and she says oh my god
some of the uh letters that this dude
sent to the police and
you know some of the stuff he left at
the scene he did like call himself lucky
or that
word did come so maybe you're on to
something so then they start delving
farther into the mystery
of if he really could be this serial
killer who has not killed anybody for
10 years now it's interesting
because at one point you almost
believe that maybe because at one point
i mean
okay so don the dad he's not dumb
and he kind of twigs on to the fact that
tyler
maybe found out some [ __ ] about him
because he for sure knows that he went
into his shed
and so he just you know suspects that he
probably saw
at least some of the [ __ ] so at first he
tries to like blow it off with
oh you know it's dudes have these
thoughts we can't help it
it's you know it's porn and it's not you
know as long as you don't do it in real
life it's not bad so they have this like
really really awkward like sex talk but
then
don pretty much suspects that he's like
okay well my kid
thinks i'm the killer now he's so tyler
i mean he's a teenager so he's not like
super good at covering his tracks i
guess so his dad is pretty much like
yeah i think he's figured it out
so he takes tyler on a camping trip now
at this point i thought the dad was just
gonna like kill tyler or it was just
gonna become
this kind of like cat and mouse kind of
[ __ ] like out in the woods or whatever
but that's not what happens which is
cool
basically what the dad does to try and
because i'm
i'm like i'd love to hear how he's gonna
get out of this one
but he says oh i'm not the clove hitch
killer
but my brother you know tyler's uncle
he's the clove hitch killer and i'm
trying to cover for him
now see the brother was in a car
accident
10 years ago and is basically
in a vegetative state he's in a
wheelchair he can't talk
it's not like he's any posit in any
position to say
hey don't throw me into the bus it's not
me so
the fact that don is like no it's my
brother i'm covering up for him because
it would
devastate the family you know the the
murder stopped because he
you know became he was in the accident
he became vegetative
and that's why it's like i just didn't
want anybody to know
and so at this point he convinces tyler
of this
because tyler i mean obviously he
doesn't want his dad to be the serial
killer and he's like it's oh it's bad
enough my uncle is the serial killer
but the dad convinces him well because
we don't want anybody finding out about
this and you
found because they find another stash of
stuff like farther down
in the crawl space or whatever under the
shed that actually has even more
incriminating [ __ ] as in like
polaroid pictures of women that kind of
look you know they're all tied up and
they kind of look dead
a whole bunch of uh driver's licenses of
all the known victims
which you know not a good look so
basically the dad's like well let's just
burn all the evidence and tyler does it
because he really doesn't want to think
that his dad is the serial killer
however
as time goes on tyler is basically kind
of like
you know what i think probably he is a
serial he is the serial killer and
spoiler alert
he does end up being the serial killer
now what this what this movie does
i guess because tyler figured out
that his dad was clove hitch don decides
he's like oh well i better get rid of
all this evidence or the son
you know or tyler's gonna like take it
all to the cops and i'll be
hosed now because he destroyed
all of his trophies which i'm guessing
were keeping him sustained for the past
decade and which is why he hadn't killed
anyone since then
but because he doesn't have that stuff
anymore he starts
getting that that hankerin to go out
and kill a woman again and so he starts
stalking this other woman that he finds
in the grocery store
now what you don't know there's like one
sequence and it's like right it's
right near probably like it's past the
middle but it's kind of like
heading toward like the final act or
whatever there's one point where he goes
to this woman's house because he like
stalks her for a couple days by the way
i
don't think i mentioned this but they
call him the clove hitch killer because
he leaves uh
a rope that's like his favorite knot
that he uses but he also
his calling card is he leaves a rope
that's tied in a clove hitch like
somewhere on the
victim's property like on the outside of
their house or whatever so he starts
stalking this woman
and he breaks into her house in the
middle of the day and he does
essentially
the same move as btk used to do he
breaks into the house
um you know after stalking them for a
few days and finding out like what their
routine is or whatever
and when there's not going to be anyone
else home and then he breaks in the
house and he says i'm not going to hurt
you i just robbed a bank i need your
car keys or whatever which was something
that uh dennis rader did as well
so he does that but then he takes the
woman in the bedroom and basically like
hogtizer and then he starts to
kill her like put a you know put a bag
over head and he starts taking polaroid
pictures
at which point his son tyler comes
into the bedroom with a rifle pointed at
his dad's head and then it fades to
black
and then i this confused me for a second
uh after it fades to black because you
don't know if he shot him or not right
so then it seems like
it i guess it jumped back in time like i
didn't
i didn't get that at first and i'm just
sitting there going wait
what what's going on now so it's so it
was a little confusing but only for like
a minute or two
like after a while i figured out oh now
we're going back in time
to show what actually happened from
tyler's perspective instead of his dad's
perspective
so turns out that this whole time that
don was stalking this woman
tyler had pretended to go off to this
boy scout leadership training
seminar thing like on the bus or
whatever so you're supposed to be out of
town
but he faked it and he came back and him
and cassie had been following
don around just to just just to figure
out like once and for all
if he's actually the serial killer so
they actually do end up saving
uh the victim because they come in the
house and there's like a really like
tense
scene toward the end where there was
another scene too and i was like
i was kind of like oh man please don't
do this dumb [ __ ] but then after i was
like oh wait no that was actually like
pretty smart because
you get back so you're seeing everything
now from the point of view of tyler and
cassie who are stalking don
you know what i mean because you've seen
everything from don's point of view you
know up to that point like him stalking
the
his next victim or whatever uh so when
they come in the house and
tyler has the gun pointing at him and
you know cassie goes over and like gets
the bag off the woman's head she's still
alive
and then don is sitting there trying to
convince tyler's like you know you're
not going to shoot me and
this it isn't how it looks and he's
trying to like rationalize it or
whatever
and he's just like uh you know i always
told you
gun safety you know don't point a gun at
anybody you don't want to use it or
anything like that and he
it seems like he convinces tyler to hand
him the gun and i was just like don't do
it kid just shoot him in the face like
you know what i mean it's like save
everyone
a lot of trouble but it was genius
because
he wanted to make absolutely absolutely
sure that
his dad would have killed him so
he hands his dad the gun but unbeknownst
to his dad that gun is not loaded
so the dad immediately points again at
tyler and pulls the trigger
so at which point tyler knows okay my
dad
is the killer uh he would have killed me
if that could have been loaded but
luckily i'm smart enough that i didn't
load it
at which point cassie knocks his ass out
and they drag
them out and um what they do is actually
the the ending i feel like a lot of
people really didn't like the way it
ended but i think
that i mean and i can see why but
i think the ending totally goes along
with
the way that the characters have been
built up up to this point
because the thing about it is that so
it ends with cassie and tyler
taking the dad and um you know cause
he's not dead he's just knocked out like
cassie knocks him out with like a big
heavy lamp or something
and then they drag him out to this camp
the campground where he
him and tyler had gone previously and
they basically
um shoot him and make it look like a
suicide right
but for a long time they don't find the
body so he's only like missing i don't
i don't know exactly like how long he's
missing i think it's long enough that
you know they set up like a little
you know funeral thing or whatever so it
was like a week or whatever but they
find his body later
and they're like yeah it looks like he
committed suicide and his family's all
broken up about it
but the thing about it is that tyler
even though he could tell everybody
that his dad was clove hitch and like
you know you know everyone would figure
it out and everything but all the
evidence is gone
so he essentially i mean the very last
scene which is actually great and it's
like him giving
a sort of eulogy for his dad like at
this you know whatever it is
it's not a funeral but it's kind of like
a celebration of life do hickey or
whatever
and the last thing you know he basically
says
everyone saw a different side of him and
all this other stuff that you know
means something if you know that he was
the serial killer but doesn't mean
anything
to anybody else and the last thing he
says if you can
hear me dad and then there's a big gap
and then he's like i love you
and then it was the end so he didn't
tell anybody
that his dad was clove hitch no one had
been killed
uh you know in the previous 10 years the
woman the
last victim that they saved hadn't seen
his face because he had a mask on
like i said much like btk used to do we
had kind of a ski mask or whatever
so she couldn't identify him either so a
lot of people
it seemed like people that didn't like
the movie were mad because they thought
well tyler should have
one he should have gone to the cops
earlier or two he should have told
everyone
but the thing about tyler was that he
didn't want there's kind of an
underlying theme
in the movie not i don't know if i'd
call it's kind of like a little sub
theme maybe it's not like overdone or
anything
there's a little thing in the movie
about rumors and how rumors about people
can ruin their lives like the rumors
about him being a perv
because the picture that was found in
the truck which wasn't even his
but because this one girl wanted to be a
twent about it
and told everybody and then everybody at
school like ostracized him because they
thought he was
all into [ __ ] bondage or whatever
which wasn't okay
in this town um and there were also
rumors going around about cassie that
she was
real [ __ ] or she was like a weirdo or
something like that
which also weren't true so i think that
one i think that you know the fact that
that had been gone into in the movie
i think that's why it ended the way it
did because tyler understood
the way that you know no it wasn't a
rumor that his dad was a serial killer
he was
but he knew that it would ruin the lives
of his
mother uh you know and he had a baby
sister and you know and
him it would they it would ruin their
lives like it would ruin the family's
lives
and i guess he felt like to what purpose
i
you know and you can agree with or
disagree with that it's like if it was
me i totally would have uh would have
said yeah he's a [ __ ] serial killer
like
nobody should be able to feel sorry that
he's dead because [ __ ] him
but in the context of the movie i think
it worked because that was kind of
the type of character that he was um and
that's absolutely
what he would have done i because i
think that he was thinking about
that him and his family still had to
live in that town and that they wouldn't
be able to
after that because even really minor
[ __ ] you know would get you ostracized
in this little
like really insular little town so i
think he just didn't want
he didn't want that to happen now you
could say on the other side of that
coin it's like well what about all the
families of the victims you know don't
they deserve any closure don't they
deserve the case to be solved
and obviously like i said that's what i
would lean toward
but as i said in the context of his
character in the context of his movie i
think that was totally
the way that it would have gone and the
way that it uh should have gone so i
actually uh
quite liked the ending even though it
was you know even though it was
personally frustrating because i was
just kind of like i'd have been up there
being like hey that killer
you know what i mean but i can see why
they didn't do that but yeah so if you
like serial killer movies as i said this
is not it's not super violent it's not
you don't really see
you actually don't even see him kill
anybody you see him do
like an attack and he ties the woman up
and it's like horrific and stuff
but you don't you know it's not a serial
killer movie in the sense that it's like
a biopic it's kind of more
exploring um you know it's kind of more
from the kids point of view
and they're you know they're kind of
like in
investigation into his uh secrecy and
his background
and the whole family dynamic of what
would happen
if you found out that your dad was a
serial killer so it's kind of much more
comes at it from a lot more like
psychological much more drama
perspective
than sort of a you know a more horror
perspective if that makes any sense
and i've seen some people i was watching
red letter media's uh did a little
breakdown of this too
and they actually kind of compared it to
um a little bit of a david fincher type
of vibe
uh you know like zodiac or something
like that which it absolutely was i
think it uh really did have that and i
think the the guy that made this movie
is also like a big david fincher fan
uh which you can see this is actually
the guy that directed it duncan skyles i
believe this is his first feature length
movie i think he'd done some shorts and
some other things
prior to this but he actually was
fascinated by serial killers
and he wanted to do a psychological
exploration like this not necessarily
the killer but
of the family surrounding it of the
community surrounding it because there's
a lot of that in it as well
and how it kind of affects the world
outside of this
killer especially like an insular little
world like this one the family and the
community and whatnot
but yeah it's it's gotten mixed reviews
but if that sounds like something that
you would like i think i thought it was
great um you know all the performances
were
fantastic and it was just like a really
fascinating
look into the psychology of that like i
said and
yeah and because that's something that
always interested me
in real cases like the btk case which
like i said this is very
which this mirrors very closely so if
that sounds like
your cup of tea then i would absolutely
recommend it as i said it came out in
2018 and it's called the clove hitch
killer and it's on hulu and amazon i
believe and it's also on netflix
so check it out and let me know what you
thought of it in the comments
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye